[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot
studio I'm Mike my Hardy I'm here with
the team from sledgehammer games we're
gonna be playing some Call of Duty
frozen dawn zombies from the upcoming
shadow war expansion to Call of Duty
World War two i'm here with richie
bracamontes he's gonna be playing with
us he's a game spots resident Call of
Duty expert I'm all here at camera
Dayton creative director from
sledgehammer games
and Jason Voorhees senior game designer
good to have both of you in the studio
we also have Jay who doesn't wanna be
call that too much but he's back here
he'll be playing with our two player
co-op zombies we're gonna jump into it
but first before we jump in
give me the elevator pitch for frozen
dawn okay well this this is the final
chapter in our Nazi Zombies epic
adventure and this is where the the
undead forces are sweeping across the
planet they have have met zero
resistance nobody's got the the armament
or the understanding to free some the
the Bureau which has been put together
at the very last second is trying to
figure out everything they can
Hank Rideau is the head of this group
knows that we've got to figure out the
mystery behind the energy that's
powering these creatures and so he had
his team head down and in the tortured
path or the lastest chapter the sword
was put together and it looked like we
have the solution but fool was not ready
to let our people go they they got on
there on an airplane they were about to
take off and you'll learn about this in
the in the beginning of the of the
frozen dawn that that fool reached out
and pulled them back down as well as an
entire Nazi Romana
and the Zeppelin's full of undead and so
they're back in the very heart you know
where it was before they may have been
on the the front porch of Thule now
they're in the very heart of what what
used to be one of the most powerful
civilizations in the history of mankind
so we're gonna solve some mysteries
we're gonna come face-to-face with some
of the most horrifying elements in our
stories today and and we're gonna answer
a lot of questions that have been
spinning so as always zombies is taking
some creative liberties with history
right why you know what we were trying
to tell a story that could have happened
I mean up until now final reich and
darkest shore we're all things we took
great care to kind of hide it in the
shadows of history yeah and then make
sure all of the technology and
everything that happened you know
possibly could have taken place with the
shadow throne we stepped out a little
bit more we took we jumped in Berlin and
that's where he took kind of a branch
and alternative history sort of then
right but we still try to keep it
roughly within the bounds of what could
have happened if there were someone dead
creatures going around cool I mean and
also even even beyond just the story
what we try to keep the easter eggs and
the stuff that happens in the level
ground it to science of some kind you
know some fantastical science yeah cool
is there anything else any other
preamble before we jump in that you want
to kind of intro what a chance they're
out but I'm just gonna say I think we're
good to you want to jump in and see
what's there
cool well rich in junior gonna be
playing like I said Ritchie's our
resident called duty expert especially
zombies but uh yeah let's uh jump in so
here we got a video here right so as
always for people who might not know
four player co-op four player co-op and
and those Slayers that have been with us
from the get-go probably unlocked all
sorts of extra cool characters we have
the hidden special characters in every
single level but if you want to get the
the meat of the story and hear all the
interactions that get some clues I
highly recommend on your first few
playthroughs do so with the four main
characters varied Rosten Jefferson and
Olivia okay and yeah we're gonna open
with a little bit of a cinematic that's
kind of setting the tone of a you know
ally forces that are just completely
overwhelmed right now with with the
undead okay Wow yes the voice of Hank
credo is done by Darren de Paul who also
does several other well-known characters
in the Activision Blizzard universe okay
alright alright
next to him that a comic-con panel yeah
and like and I didn't know it was him
and then Michael Chu the lead writer
from a heart and he's like I think we
have a voice actor the audience and I
didn't know is right next me all of a
sudden he yelled out like no and then
we've got a Helen Sadler does the voice
of Vivian Harris back here as well she's
a very talented voice actor so so we can
see we are just being overrun we need to
find the sword the sword unfortunately
went down in the burning Iraq that we
see right here so our characters are
trying to figure out what's gonna happen
and they need to look for the sword they
need to answer some mysteries okay cool
so one thing I noticed when I played
what sorry forgive me what was the name
of the first zombies from World War two
the final rank the final right but I
played the final Reich the thing that
struck me was how much more it felt like
a multiplayer raid almost in the
objectives that you were doing obviously
the zombies always had those like if you
wanted to just fight off waves obviously
with not gonna tell it the first one you
could but also there's like packed lunch
stuff the the story gets introduced but
more than anything now the final reich
felt like an actual like oh we have to
really figure out this puzzle to advance
to the next objective it reminded me of
like a destiny range something else a
story something that i loved about this
dlc and just a touch a little bit on dlc
3 that torture path we wanted in torture
paths to do something different we
wanted to check you know just jostle up
what the standard zombies experience is
and we did a really good job I know we
had some opinions back and forth but I I
really think we nailed it yeah this one
we want to what to go back to this you
know the kind of the core the
inspirational zombies experience and
this you'll notice you know if you if
you played it if you haven't you should
the Easter egg in this path is a little
bit more it is less TFR it's not as
linear and there's a lot to do yeah it's
just so much to do actually that a lot
of people have gratefully stumbled upon
little bits and pieces and we've been
watching some you know Cameron I've been
watching streams we were up all night
last I want the
the unraveling and that's everything
there's no one central way to solve this
or go through you kind of get to choose
your own adventure I guess you could say
but yeah but carrying out a lot of what
we have fun right
story is a big part of the sledgehammer
take on Nazis and we wanted it to be
something with a very little gaming hand
with yeah there there is a there's a
reason behind everything you see that's
taking place in this game a narrative
reason behind as well as writing play
reason and the it's it's it's a lot of
fun being on the tail end of the DLC
right now because we've got a team a
sound team animation art design team
that that has perfected their use of
these tools perfected how they create
with it this is a corpse eater yeah he's
kind of our new look I knew our new bad
guy the corpse eater is Ari
I guess he's officially not a nazi
zombie he's a Thule in zombie so it's
like the original civilization kind of
do not like an act exactly but he's
these were the the the people who
figured out how to bring the dead back
to life I got so how to use you know
what the Nazis later called guys craft
and and so now that the the city is
beginning to store the ice is beginning
to melt the blood is beginning to run
through the city we're seeing some of
the the most powerful members of the
civilization some of the greatest
warriors are waking up again and of
course when they get up big they're
starving the city is starving before for
the energy that's been stolen and so the
first thing they're gonna go for is is
the zombies that are powered by this
energy they're gonna try and regenerate
and rejuvenate themselves and once
they're you know
satiated they're they're probably gonna
go after one blooded individuals so I
highly recommend you you get in on them
and knock them out before they get all
filled up because they're gonna get a
lot
you know something you mentioned I just
love the art design and the level design
really the design of this whole level
there the idea that this city fool this
ancient city is starving yeah it has
been sitting here for it like hi yeah
under the eye it's just waiting for
something to finally awaken it and so
there's you know you see in one of the
other areas actually kind of beneath
that window that you were walking around
just couple seconds ago there's these
just glacial melts of red it looks like
blood maybe it's blood maybe it's mine
well this was inspired by actual
photograph so you've seen these
photographs of glaciers and Antarctica
that are pouring with red it's very iron
rich sea otter gotcha it looks like
blood relates way cooler yeah yeah and
so I like let's play into that and you
know I one of my favorite little bits of
like trivia that I like to annoy you
with is the fact that that chemically
sea water and human blood are not that
different you know when you get down to
the core breakdown obviously the blood
cells are different so anyway joking but
so before I forget I'm sure our last I
will ask you again later on but you said
some streamers are playing frozen Don
right now yes but when can people
watching get into this and play this
plus me yeah yeah everybody can we're
arrived last of all yeah we wanted to
make a play yet watch this stream or
watch a play right yeah that's the we we
wanted to make sure we really worked
hard to make sure that when this hit
everybody was at the starting gate at
the exact same time and and yeah that's
the the pride of like finishing Easter
eggs first and getting world's first and
discovering something first
is something the entire community gets
in on yeah and so so we do everything we
can to make sure that that everybody can
get in when they won when that timer
beeps yeah we were talking about this
before but I imagine well you said it's
a little bittersweet right this is the
last DLC under sledgehammer before you
know you hand off the reins two trailers
have been marketing black ops for
already but this is your it's still you
know under sledgehammer right we're also
really excited
yeah sure right you're so excited to
play to get in and our brothers a track
are doing an amazing job we're so
exciting events you just got into the
depth Raven events oh yeah good luck but
as far as you know working hands-on with
stuff every day this is this is the last
you know major expansion to the game
right like correct what's that like
going into that well it's it's
interesting because it's like I said
earlier each of our teams has really
perfected the art the craft of building
these games so this is I believe one our
most beautiful levels when our most
intricately designed levels one of our
most challenging levels when you guys
see the boss fight yeah that's a thing
of beauty and oh we just totally psyched
okay which is you're gonna have you can
have some fun with the sign this is one
of my favorite melee weapons so so you
love seeing like the team really have
kind of the apex of their abilities with
having and I think it is a fantastic way
to close out you always want to end with
the bin you always gonna end with that
something that's gonna make people
hungry for more yeah but yeah also you
know where a lot of the team is now
looking forward to to you know to what's
happening next and so that's we had a
kind of a celebration dinner about this
this DLC bow out the other day and it
was a I got a little emotional it was
yeah it's been a it's been a great team
to work with not going for that mg42
yeah sup wait did i sorry did jade
purchased a cipher was there some other
thing that oh no this survived the first
ricci still stuck with his a trench tool
looks like that's all right that's right
you gotta have the trench tools too you
gotta have a shovel I mean talk about
it's like the inception of this DLC - we
had a really interesting experience
usually we get together we start talking
about what we want to do and so we got
together and you know Cameron pitched
the you know the setting to the whole
level and we just started talking and
there was very little knows everyone who
was involved letting seeing the audio
team the environment our team the
animation
they loved the concept right away yeah
so we got to hit the ground running and
just go and we also you know we're
pretty pressed for time so we wanted to
make sure to get everything we possibly
could into this level and I think we did
an amazing job the team knocked apart
and there are a lot of things like if
you go back now and you play for
instance the shadow of the throne you'll
see okay that's where we were trying out
how to melee weapons work with this game
you know we had a bunch of array of
melee weapons that we kind of introduced
there we wanted to see how they worked
in the game we also wanted to see how
the audience how the players dealt with
that you know cuz I mean this is largely
a this game is a shooter you know and so
so are we gonna have a good audience
response to a bat with nails in it and
dagger and all these other things and
the response was overwhelmingly positive
which which we just took is uh you know
we we've been aiming for the release of
these you know the Raven Lords weapons
here and but we got to kind of practice
some practice swings in shadow throne
and towards this and that's something I
love about the DLC season is is there's
an evolution of our understanding what
the audience wants as well as a
complexity of the design as we as we
move fast the each chapter yeah one
thing that's been super fun for me to
watch as someone who has been with
zombies since Nocturne totin it's been
awesome to see you know once Infinity
Ward and such ever also started doing
zombies right obviously Infinity Ward
for the first time was doing it with if
the warfare last year that was the first
time an accident zambese it's been cool
to see each studio as a take on that
obviously Treyarch establishing it with
what was very much a pet project at the
time okay I'll set it up into like many
people myself included kind of stuck
with a series largely as a result of
zombies over anything else obviously
there's the three pillars of zombie
multiplayer campaign Oh zombies a
multiplayer now with a black ops for
coming out but zombies very much become
its own thing does AMA Chronicle that
came out last year was awesome to play
her all those classics the funny thing
you know crazy just uses very key it was
a pet project yeah that's the whole
zombies venire the game every version of
this has been a product of love from the
development team yeah it's so much fun
to work on this stuff it's so much fun
to work on this stuff it's so much fun
to watch people play it afterwards
I want to be part of it part of the
community we've got probably one of the
most active vocal sharply critical
communities in that out in gaming and we
love it because it means that we're
gonna know immediately we're gonna have
a temperature gauge of you know what did
we change that was appreciated what do
we change that was viciously hated would
it be changed that was you know what
were their seeing some some hope right
there and it's a it's like a force of
nature that we try to be aware of and
included with and and that's part of the
fun I mean it's like Christmas morning
the night after the release and we're
watching everybody you've got the gap
sapore the the grumbling the cheers and
everything else and the you know a lot
of these mysteries and easter eggs that
we spent months calculating and twisting
and tying up seeing them which ones are
unraveled the quickest and which ones do
the when characters or when when when
players will run by something twelve
times like oh they missed it again okay
what kind of cheering for them to to go
down in flames we do sit at the office
of the command center with like a bunch
of streams all just live right it's like
an NSA office and we yeah it kind of
feels like you know watching football or
something and yeah someone's just almost
there and you're like ah way to get it
the stock exchange yeah yeah which
actually reminds me if you are watching
right now on YouTube for GameSpot and
you've been playing this since it came
out early early this morning or you're
you're thinking about getting into it
later today I did come in on Twitter I
can't promise they'll be able to answer
all of them if they're like spoiler
territory but if you want to tweet at
one of us on Twitter I'm Emma Hardy and
if you have any questions specifically
for camera to Jason here again I can't
promise they'll be able answer
everything but we're not telling you
what's happening with the shield or
someone that was the first one
it was yeah so explain that to me what's
is it some mysterious thing going on but
the guy has it figured out
the main Easter Egg path is about four
weapons it's the scythe the hammer the
Morningstar how the shield okay and they
figured out how to get the base version
and the Empowered version of the scythe
the hammer and the Morningstar event but
they haven't gotten very far on the
shield yet - yeah which is by the way my
easter egg that's right oh you pro
designers kind of took a weapon and was
it was kind of their focus and so we're
kind of like counting coup and carrying
points according to like who's whose
weapons got figured out sooner and which
ones are more challenging me and Shawn
we're neck-and-neck and mainly figured
out the hangouts oh yeah and so uh the
but but I think we can safely say this
when you unlock the powers for each of
these weapons it just opens up an
entirely new dimension of play and so
you might have your favorites right now
wait until you see what they can do out
there I have to at their utmost it
really do you want to listen to what
what is being whispered in the in the
shadows behind you because the yeah
there's some important important clues
being left it's so astounding to me that
the game can be I mean I know it hasn't
been out long but that frozen dawn can
be out even of several hours and someone
somewhere still hasn't figured something
out
oh yeah I mean 2018 for that so that's
that's a pillar in school video game can
the power of collective consciousness
the fact that we've got I mean we've got
there you know our intrepid you know
YouTube and twitch influencers that are
out playing but behind every single one
of them is an army of fans watching all
the other channels playing themselves
giving in that that feedback and and so
yeah for us every hour that goes by is a
win mints many a day where we were just
clever enough or I mean not to mention
an e and F are evil enough to hide it
yeah for another hour one of the most
interesting things is also hearing you
know some of the major streamers say oh
I wonder if it's this way and then they
have 15 people with supposition that are
completely wrong in some direction and
of course I'm sitting you know back
behind the stream just like you got it
dude just go with your gut you know this
I believe in you I'm sure you can't talk
about like the whole process behind it
but and I know like obviously Treyarch
infinity ward's sledgehammer you know
you work you share ideas you worked
pretty closely as you despite being
individual studios but when you were
finishing this up like how much was how
much like consciously were you saying
alright this is our last one were you
worried at all maybe not worries write
work over you it was a conscious in the
front of your mind and saying oh we're
about to hand it off to Treyarch or i
mean i know it's very much your stamp on
it but how much of it was like oh we're
about to hand it back off we gotta we're
we're very conscious of like you know
I'm in touch with Lee and Jason and they
we kind of know what we're all working
on yeah and so so we kind of got our own
space and at this point it's very we
very much got our own signature styles
and kind of our signature way of playing
and in fact we've made changes
throughout the course of our seasons
just being conscious of hey you know
track is going there and is gonna do
this so let's steer clear that's their
space and so it's a it's funny because a
lot of the fanciest is these like
competing groups or these you know these
kind of enemies and in actuality we're
we're all carrying the zombies torch and
we're just all kind of hitting a
different type of audience and kind of
telling a different sort of a story and
we're all cheering for each other's
successes so we cannot wait to see what
happens with the this new era of zombies
or Treyarch and and yeah we've got some
big big plans of the future as well yeah
it is funny it's also funny like that
you know with black ops 4 you're going
back to a futuristic kind of more
features like than this style this
fertile you know presumably for a while
will be the last World War 2 expansion
for a coffee shop or who knows how long
sure but yeah that's that's it's always
fascinating to me how again like the
split fact the Treyarch kind of you know
pioneered the Nazi Zombies like how
infinity ward's ledge ever picked it up
and put their own take on it like you
could play a Call of Duty game for five
minutes and be like oh this is infinity
order this and that I think is is is a
mark of the success of the art
actors the design director is the the
creative directors on each of those
teams is putting their their stamp on it
and their mark on on the game and and
and and here's the interesting thing
some people it's just like you know food
or music or anything else some people
that will jive with some people that
won't and you know we just we just want
to make sure that the audience that
zeroes in on our style of game on our
style of story feel like it is the very
best the most well crafted thing that
they've encountered you know so like for
people who've been watching it we're
watching Jays footage Richie is playing
with them two-player co-op what are we
looking at here there are waivable 12
now actually just finished 11 what's
what's the situation here so far without
spoiling anything I guess well Jake for
instance how would you power out the
shield
maybe to tell us that no straight up no
no no we're not even gonna say she'll
like CJ did well I'm gonna say shield a
second but Jay just picked up the base
level Thule in sight and he just got
this shield dropped so you should
probably grab that shield I was fine I
guess straight where he's gonna go
shield and weapon you should definitely
grab that sight though I mean that's a
little big : black energy right there to
your luck there you go you can also you
can only a huge player can have one
that's nice okay I thought you could
just be the same oh wait oh there's a
reason there's a reason why people okay
so each weapon is actually tied to one
of the Raven lives okay and and and
there's there's a theme in the type of
energy and the type of damage in the
and the effects that each of these
weapons have that is that is tied to
those rated ones and and this plays a
big part in our story their abilities
are kind of a balance to the overall
undead energy the tap and even the the
attacks and the abilities that each the
weapons do resonate with the core of
that rhythm or as well and there's a
purpose for each of their abilities so I
think a play it looks like the shield is
like crowd control a little bit like
almost like I'm an evil or an old school
riot shield and with magical force bill
powers but no we don't say magical
magical is not a sci-fi dancer yes right
yeah this is again it's kind of funny
because we've talked so much about
grounding so much of our story in
science and I've got you know I've
gotten notes of exactly how the fear of
science works I find everything we've
got here it may seem magical but that's
just that's just science you have an
unwrapped yeah yeah I won't have them
looking for that's a wonderful harvest
hey Jay you want to yeah hey Jay take a
soak so this is you know the the
carvings the decor there's nothing in
this in our levels is there by accident
yeah everything has meaning everything
has a reason that there could open up a
little bit more understanding about how
why where and when and so I'm gonna I'm
gonna recommend that you keep your eyes
open I
I see a lot of I mean running and
escaping the undead horde behind you is
a big part of this game if you get a
chance and you can have somebody else
you know kite the end of somewhere else
get a chance to look around look on the
walls see what's see what's written see
what's what's Illustrated and
couldn't make things go a little easier
for it again if you can't answer thee
just let me know move on but uh beanbag
money on Twitter says is the dark room a
glitch or are you meant to be stuck in
there no there's definitely bug okay
we'd have a fix incoming its data hype
right now
okay quite some people have figured out
what that room is for I'm very proud of
them okay so there's a purpose to the
room there's a purpose for the purpose
support like never said there's nothing
in there well yeah yes good segue okay
beanbag money thank you me I'm trying to
like read these through to make sure
they before I say them out loud okay
cool so question to cameron dane
specifically this is from ed 59 on
twitter is there more to the story once
we're done with this map or is this a
pretty definitive finale be as vague as
you need we love this season thanks for
the hard work guys um we appreciate that
so much so a lot of a lot of what we
like to do when we're building a
fictional universe is is create
something that feels like there's a lot
going on outside of just what's
happening with the characters there and
we've been releasing letters and notes
scribbles and and and things from from
some of our other characters throughout
the season to give that that that sense
and so right now we're with our four
main characters and we're we're
finishing the arc of their character
we're finishing the article what they
didn't go out there we're gonna answer a
lot of questions in this story however
we have now set up a world that has
drastically changed from from the the
very historic world war two universe
that we were in before and this is a
world where the undead are now moving
against the the living civilizations
that exist we've just woken up an
antediluvian society here that had all
sorts of that is used to controlling
everything we've got a new bureau that's
kind of an international group of bureau
of archaic technologies that is uh now
taking a very powerful seat in the in
the world stage the the forces of Nazi
Germany are still still very active
right now so while we may finish up this
this tale its
universe where there are countless more
stories to be told
yeah so thank you ed fifty nine and then
Jaden Brooks was asking are the melee
weapons the only wonder weapons the
frozen Don for future reference are
there any more that we could be looking
for we don't we don't like to give any
definitive stuff as of yet until that
right yeah all right Jaden Brooks thank
you for the question regardless yeah
good question we know what you're going
for with that eleven
yeah like I said if you're watching and
you have any more questions tweet at me
at em my Hardy and I'll get hand them
over to Jason or Cameron throughout the
stream thank you for every for watching
on youtube or GameSpot you guys are
doing pretty well play fourteen yeah
this is all day right yes we have this
site and the shields will yep yeah oh
yeah back to chase lady I see this base
level yeah
what like Jay Jay is familiar with the
layout yeah
now know which weapon was Jays focus Jay
was the safe
Jay Jay created the scythe and the
mystery around the side band dad
there's I think there's a reason it's a
lot of people's favorite something it's
just it's fun to use it's so spicy yeah
dude I was I was we have a lot of
animations to go into this and I was so
happy when the animators gave me be back
and forth back and forth
feels so good yeah it feels so good
especially when it's empowered you see
although it was pretty sad just
ridiculously amazing the effects yeah
we're really into just the I mean
there's the there's the craft of making
games right there's the progression
there's the the math I guess we would
call it the the algorithm behind behind
making things fun but there's also
there's element of the art to where it
just feels good yeah you know it's
something you'll see and a lot of like
the classic Nintendo games or you know
we're just the jumping slicing and that
was something that was really important
for all of the melee weapons but uh but
yeah there's I don't the word slicing is
probably not as I don't know if that's
the King's English or not but uh but it
just it's so satisfying right now it's
just I mean I definitely I've been
watching
place the shield - they're definitely
not playing with it right which it makes
me happy because they'll figure it out
of it when they'll figure to actually
write and it's good you want to drop
something about the shield there I can
barely adequately convey how many
questions are pouring it about the
shield I guess I guess what I'll say is
just it's it's right there guys
oh this is a you're just that you're
just missing it I've watched you do it I
watched you get close some of you have
even talked about the actual next step
yeah well here's actually that's the
best part is when they're throwing out
like ten ideas and like the third idea
is like oh they got it and then for some
reason everybody ignores the guy who
came up with yeah yeah I'm not gonna
tell you who it's those the one of you
within the first half-hour commented on
part actually it's been said it's been
like you said it hyped about someone
gets it a run chat it's like no it's not
it so here's a question I'm fairly
certain this would be a spoiler if you
answered Carrie Lee Anne Smith on
Twitter but speculating are the four
characters going to be the new rated
Lords that is a fantastic speculation
you know there are there four of them
there are four Raven Lords the N and I
am so not going to answer that question
I'm sorry but but it is a great question
okay I'll tell you what the answer to
that question is it's in the Frozen
Throne okay give it a play dumb question
- Cameron Dayton directly huh those
three cloud symbols in altar of blood I
need answers
well I think I could probably answer
they're so luxe Lucifer saved us saying
ask Cameron Jason if we can expect a
possible sequel right now this is the
definitive finale for world war ii
zombies this use existing this is the
closing of this chapter okay all right
so I have like along with frozen dawn
what else is in shadow war that we that
people could be playing look at some
fantastic multiplayer maps just so it's
a really cool and and we're kind of blur
the lines one of my favorite things with
this product is being able to work
with the MP team the multiplayer team
and the single-player team and so we've
got this is historically this is the
very first zombies mode that has
characters from single player that has
map elements from multiplayer where
we've gone back and forth and made sure
that there was a connective tissue so so
when you have the World War 2 disc
you're not jumping between you know
different weird you know theoretical and
universes or whatever it all is very
consistent you find some offensive MVP
you do some summer events you find some
salts and drown zombies you get a charm
or two from zombies you bring them into
NP we love it actually we love being
able to go back and forth like yeah yeah
I just don't remember the day when I
like I signed them to youtube or
something and then I saw that Johnny
Trejo was gonna be in the zombies like
what is going on I think that was the
first one we're like actual people were
put into it yeah obviously like Jeff
Goldblum down in hurling there later on
but the fact that Johnny Trejo that was
the arctic I forgot that was black ops 2
maybe with yeah that's a killer yeah
around Justin mr. SOG on Twitter was
asking is there any update on the
tortured path survival maps releasing to
everyone we're still we're still trying
to make that work we're trying to I'm
trying to get that through and that
there's a reason when I put that tweet
out that I put in didn't put a timeline
on it and so so it's a it's something
we're still very very much focused on
man Jason really riled some people are
in a good way so now there's people
asking if it was their team or their
stream where the they said it was just
another UK game you're gonna answer we
why he was you asking you can we watch a
lot that Manchester crowd boy and he
loved me both oh here's a good one this
kid so looks looser for safe who asked
for priests question said Cameron if
Jason do you have any recommendations
for books to read for the inspiration of
oh you know I like to do I like to mix
up when I'm reading I like to get into
some you know the good picture stuff I
like watching a lot of films I've got a
fantastic two thousand page book on
Emperor Barbarossa which is like like
plays a lot of the the core mythology
behind what we've got what we've got
going here
the really a lot of the comics by Mike
Mignola if you read me the Hellboy
volumes check those out because because
Manila does a very similar things he
bases a lot of it on actual history I
hid as actual grave rubbings like a lot
of the art in there is taken from
architecture is taken from actual
historic elements so so definitely look
into that and I mean there's there's a
lot we've got a lot of fun science that
goes into what we've been building with
this again so I'll tell you what I'm
gonna put a list of the the books that I
use for reference for this on Twitter
when we're done here and you guys want
to check that out it's funny I don't
wanna give away too much actually but a
lot of the inspiration that came from
this map
from you know various media right I
don't know if you guys have played at
this board game one of my favorite
called Kingdom death it has about big
monsters and weapons and surviving this
kind of horror situation there's
actually this great book I don't know if
you've read this one in sub Rio it's
very it's it's like 15 years old
it's talks about necromancy and the dead
and they use bells to resonate how the
the undead rise and fall and it feels
really interesting
you've been really into the resonation
that's great they're using bells as like
a metaphor or as a tool to raise the
power of simple vibration alright but
yeah there's a lot of stuff in it it's
it's fun because again there's there's
something about the kind of the
collective creativity of the team and so
a lot of times we'll come in and we will
bring in videos movies you know are we
we open on very much a strong horror
knows yeah you know the team has their
their DNA is in horror games dead space
a lot of Lovecraft yeah a lot of
Lovecraftian stuff so you order it up
with that because poor it tends to be a
little more of a of an intimate story
you know we started with a very personal
story with Marie and and her brother
Klaus and what was happening but as the
as the as the stage grew bigger for this
we were this story is evolved into more
of a bigger kind of worldwide adventure
that's taking place and and that was a
deliberate strategy however we wanted to
make sure that we we ended on a we kind
of had a bookend that echoed the first
and so you're going to be seeing a lot
of those same notes of for personal
realization and
and little did you know as a ploy over
this is where it all started and yeah so
yeah some of those horror elements are
extremely important and the you know the
adventure II aspect of the Indiana Jones
descent into an ancient location that's
also incredibly important and also
implied TFR you know yeah what's the
first zombies you worked on Jason
I worked it's much on the final wreck
but I was primarily on island beyond
so-called world war two first exhibit
short and well yeah we I mean we brought
service so Jason was initially on the
single-player team and and it's funny I
as we're building these maps he came
over he's like well just so you know
we've got this map but I've kind of
thrown some zombies spawners in like
like he had the passion for what we were
doing so much design your next expansion
yeah yeah I started robot like I was
never on to our team I was like 75% done
with Normandy in the campaign level up
and they were starting the zombies team
and one of my buddies at the company was
the lead for a little while and we were
talking about all these different crazy
ideas and how could work so I was even
back then before the team was even made
I was like I kind of wanna can I like
yeah
yes we got - we went to Infinity Ward
Lowell two years ago or no what was it
yeah so at this point two years ago
before infinity infinite warfare came
out and we were talking to the zombies
team I forget last name Brian was one of
the leads on the zombies team and at
that point it was about to be the
amusement park the 80s amusement parks
okay that was like last time very fun
the dance floor was was awesome
well this is gonna fight cuz I'm common
a kid I grew up in that era so I like it
was not only a fun map but I love the
feeling of throwback I knew their
audience yes
yeah I was not a nice kid but Hasselhoff
yeah but it also it's set a great tone
that we could play off as as well you
know we're like okay if that is Infinity
Ward they've set a flag on that style
and the tongue-in-cheek yeah fun you
know kind of soldiers commentary and so
with that flag set were like we've got
this great space over here where we can
do much more on the nose for Andy
Ashmore you know and and we've had a
couple times we we had a opportunity to
go zany and kind of go off the beaten
path I think probably the closest we've
ever gotten to that is there a zombie
leprechaun yeah yeah and he was chasing
you down yeah stealing your jewels mobs
right yeah like an actual like some
parts of like Irish folklore leprechauns
are is legit I mean ours a legit horror
franchise talk about that for a second
though I love the fact I wasn't part of
the leprechaun development but I love
the fact that we got a scary little
creature who had a scary gameplay
component that was kind of annoying but
it really worked well you want to deal
with this guy so you had to turn your
focus on him when I respond well and
we're gonna having a little bit of kind
of buzz so you for some letters went out
there's so much chilling are like oh
it's into our Lord there's some money
there's some some some letters went out
that kind of explains some of dr.
Strauss more pushing the envelope
experiments with with different types
you got the pencil more towards
fortifying wait till you see the
Leprechaun away but uh wave nineteen all
right you still got the scythe Ritchie
unupgraded
I would assume yeah well yeah no
progress at all and then to answer your
question we've uh the the undead stuff
even before getting over to sledgehammer
I've been like I was at Blizzard during
the Lich King expansion of Warcraft I've
done some some riding over on the
creative development side around that
game obviously with
three we had a lot of fun undead stuff
we got to do and then I dipped into
mobile for a while and did a Walking
Dead game with with scope Lee down in LA
okay so I these undead projects just
seem to what's a horrible metaphor rise
from the grave when working on something
so new so a lot of that experience was
what pushed us into doing such a unique
zombie story that we didn't want to do
voodoo we didn't want to do black magic
stuff we didn't want to do biological
bacterial viral infection stuff cuz
that's that's kind of a modern way to go
with things and so we looked at okay
what was happening in science in this
era and there were some amazing
understandings of physics understandings
of the atom you know this is when the
nuclear bomb was being first first
developed and and whatever was being
done in Germany and so so we said let's
let's play with physics let's see what
we can do that that would still be a
feasible way of animating dead flesh and
you know we talked about this a little
bit but the one of my favorite things
about the the you know fantasy of the 30
and 40 is early 40s is that kind of
adventure of descending into crypts and
finding old stuff you know I didn't have
the internet back then so whatever they
found they would have to just kind of
imagine what it was and the technology
at the time was just good enough to get
into these places that have previously
been out of Rita had been inaccessible
so we were able to dig deeper go further
but we still working on you know walkie
talkie isn't stuff like that so you were
still very much adventuring you
basically had you know the pistol on
your belt and the whip on your back and
yeah you know whoever you've been able
to bring when you're not and you're yeah
I'm not trying to push that one too much
okay - I'm but yeah but that's the
feeling end and that's I think builds
into the sense of horror with our
characters they're there all alone
they're not nobodies that the calories
not coming to rescue our crew and
they've got to piece these mysteries
together now one of my favorite things
is are when you've got people digging
into ruins they're their academics sure
they're warriors sure they know how to
you know
the weapon but but by-and-large each of
the members of our team here are experts
in engineering in history in art and and
in cultures and so so you listen to
their to what they say a lot of times we
you know illuminating as to where to go
next
that being said I could totally imagine
David Tennant ascending a rope down into
a pair of it something about that end of
doing anything I mean probably right
lavish Lucas a couple times was asking
if you'll be able to play as odds from
exo-zombies
going back to advanced warfare I believe
I think I can safely answer them no yeah
how many years ago was that at this
point three years yeah oh it would make
sense the other rotation there's a lot
of clumps and AHS fans and dimensions oh
yeah what can I should like close what
is a cool character well they should
have in class really like you were
paying attention to the notes that he
left in the final right Klaus was was
instrumental to our understanding or
really what's been happening because
well he was you know kind of co-opted by
dr. Stromm and brought on as a cult it's
a really nice word yeah yeah that's the
gentle term he was so fascinated by by
the history and the science that was
saying was because he was a physicist he
was studying engine one of Germany's
most most advanced schools and then had
his career cut short by his father
falling ill and eating him to come back
to the toy shop and then all of a sudden
he finds himself at the at the you know
root level of a brand new understanding
of physics and so it's really his his
notes that have given the bureau and
Murray a sense of what's going on with
what's happening I got Tony Albuera on
Twitter this isn't really a question but
he was saying thank you for implementing
the shovel melee blitz option into the
game was a great idea that promotes use
of the may life her we appreciated that
yes good talk buddy shovel variance I
actually want to give a little shout-out
to one of our coworkers
the shovel variance is one of one of our
guys just like you know that is we've
said so yeah thank you for letting the
shovel may lay buried yeah yeah no I
mean like we've wanted it to for a while
we've heard you asking one of the guys
actually stayed really late a couple of
nights in a row implement it because he
knew it was so important I was like
something so cool you get these amazing
variants why shouldn't be able to bring
them to Zambia so or later thank you to
see Borowski that was fee Borowski who
we has been with our crews since the
final rank has been responsible for so
many of the innovations and cool stuff
there and a lot of what he does is just
it is a labor of love and yeah he saw
and heard all the shoutouts for that and
that was that was all him yeah yeah this
is for camera and worki any chance of
getting additional supplemental material
featuring back stories on the bureau
operatives like the mountaineer and the
survivalist
oh yeah I mean this is this is our
favorite stuff to do this is our you
know writing those bachelors I love that
the communities have been able to slip
out that the Mountaineer was actually
the Russian operative that we heard in
the radio in the shadow throne so this
is this oh so yes you plan to do to do
more of more storytelling more backstory
more interesting character stuff just
because I can't not do that I can't shut
up about it
yeah this is I think you might guess my
visiting this is the first place you'll
ever hear this the all of our all of our
characters that have been recruited by
the Bureau are essentially heroes
characters who have students stand out
for their their military prowess their
academic understanding their just their
abilities throughout the the war
throughout World War two
some of them are very loosely based on
actual heroes and granted we're now in
kind of a skewed alternate timeline but
uh you might have some fun exploring and
looking
for what where's this coming from who is
this character they're good like
historical figure oh they're getting
inundated by Corsi look at more series
that are looks like they've been
feasting yes we saw that well the corpse
eater was one of the ones we saw earlier
right yeah yeah on streaming was just
there's about three or four of them
consuming those zombies nearby and the
Jade skillfully took them out before
they finished and then John Rizzo who
asked that question also John whose idea
was it to cross over some of the
campaign elements into zombies yeah that
was initially something I pushed for
from the team I just uh the we just had
all these amazing stories being told on
the singleplayer amazing characters
having been built and because I really
wanted to one thing that I wanted to
make kind of our sledgehammer stamp of
uniqueness was you put that disk in
whether you do single-player multiplayer
of zombies you're still feel like you're
you're you're in the same sort of a
universe you know our initial pitch for
zombies was this is in the shadow
history and this is taking place and
there's no better way to cement that
than bringing in other characters so I
loved the you know Vivian's character in
the single-player story
I wanted her to get a little more
limelight a little more kind of exposed
really glad you do yeah and and there
are actually some elements that bleed
across from both sides yeah I wonder if
anybody found these super small minor
Easter Egg that I put in Normandy for I
don't know why don't you just say
there's a super small easter egg in
normal first campaign level yeah yeah
yeah because we've been talking about
this this from the get-go but it's a
it's something that the team was 100%
behind and it's a it's been really great
because it means that we can build off
of a greater story you know sort of the
meta story behind everything really my
advance apologies if this is like
someone's throwing shade I don't think
it is but Lucas rise to it says ask
Cameron what ride go is up to I don't
like his an attitude nose up to I don't
like it's a head
no no not you yeah no that's where those
just leave it there no question because
this is this has all been written yes
this is all out there Rideau went from
being the head of the the monuments of
fine art administration to to heading up
the the Bureau of archaic technologies
and so he's had a perspective on this
through the Allied side of the the Nazi
rise to power through this this undead
you know force and and and how it's it's
slowly just swept across and just not
decided I mean the impediments he's also
aware that the Nazis are losing control
of it as well like they're trying to
maintain an air of managing this but but
the undead are obviously being being
moving controlled by by a much more
ancient more powerful force that was
using the Nazis to allow them to surface
and so weirdos just got a broader
perspective on things and he's been
debating with with Vivian about should
we go all in on this Hail Mary should we
send our best warriors in to go get the
sword because we know the sword we don't
quite understand everything happening
but we know the sword is key and and
there were some debate about that but he
sees like all of our best weapons all of
our you know the the strength of the
Allied forces just keep falling
underneath the this undead presence and
so he's the sword is a Hail Mary it's
there it's really their last hope to get
that through the team grabbed it in the
tortured path of the very end they were
able to put it together and then their
plane went down and so if a sword has
been lost listen to the radio stuff
you're gonna be hearing more about
Rideau about his communication he's he's
betting everything on the
being able to find that and then what's
been happening here so yeah I think he's
got he's got a very unique perspective
of what's happening and he actually
might be the one more genuinely and
legitimately scared than anybody else
because of that perspective okay yeah
lapis Lukas s can you talk about
unsolved Easter eggs I'm assuming
they'll say keep playing yes there are
some there are okay and then Ryan hold
stock this doesn't this might be one you
can hit that with the blood quotes are
they vital and how literally should we
take them
oh all of the courts are vital vital as
I said there's no weapons that are
speaking to you for a reason
okay yeah yeah I think Klaus Klaus is is
just echoing Klaus is taking a role and
is echoing something that has been said
and needs to be said that's that's
something you mentioned this before like
there's not much in in zombies that you
there's nothing in there that you put in
them it's not vital and that's just
interesting to me about designing like
you know zombies map obviously campaign
is very tight and multiplayer but
multiplayer is allowing for you know PvP
and whatnot but zombies you can be very
concise it's almost like a short story
kind of uh you know that I mean it can
be very long but it's like this short
story chapter of the Call of Duty
Universe so you can make sure everything
in there is essential as this story
we're trying to tell a big story trying
to sell an epic story we're trying to do
a lot trying to do some innovations and
and but we have we have a very you know
tight-knit and and it's a smaller team
that's doing this and so that means we
have to be earlier we set out
aerodynamic and we like the term necro
dynamic with this cousin right there so
gonna like a copy right that we have a
we have something in the level 2 that is
necro dynamic I'm just gonna make though
whatever yeah entry so satchel and so so
yeah they're like we just we don't have
the kind of team or the kind of timeline
where we can be putting a lot of
frosting in this and so there there's a
point to a lot of what's going on and
you may recognize and see things from
previous levels that that's not by
accident if you see that there
and and this might be a good time to say
there are still some Easter eggs in the
previous levels know what their doubts
though greg FPS was asking do you have
any specific inspirations for the
puzzles scattered throughout frozen Don
oh absolutely I mean obviously preview
yeah no zombies but maybe outside
sources I love talking about this book
because this is this is really the fun
all of the Easter eggs in the frozen
dawn are based on the weapon I mean as
you probably figured out but there's
interesting thing you know interesting a
little bit of kind of fiction behind all
these drawings they're all based in some
kind of science there's some kind of
like if you looked really closely the
Ori for example is based on that planet
it you know it was actually an ordering
a real star chart and that will
mechanism function was kind of hard an
order would function and the star map
works how it starting off would work so
you know because something you've always
been fascinated Lobster been a hobby of
yours anyway for me I just like the
scene in the Dark Crystal sound like I
want something like that and Jason gave
his meaning in heart I mean maybe maybe
I had that best movie and that book at
home so this is speculation but Apple
Man one was saying sorry Jan my Nord on
Twitter was saying how long do you think
it will take for the Easter eggs to get
solved all you just said there were some
that aren't even solved we have we have
bets
yeah share them I mean it's really
interesting because I want to be right
and also want to be wrong and watch you
guys to enjoy it and the time it takes
you to figure it out is old kind of it
is cheesecake to us yeah yeah it's it's
so is the record it didn't get a shout
out throne pulled the longest record for
Twitter cross towards your path actually
that's right that's right so so we've
progressively
been able to create Easter eggs that are
taking longer Linder aye my money is on
this one taking longer than any of them
that the shield specifically is that
next round I know I saw me
I don't want it to be less than torture
path to more than everyone in Marrakesh
or yeah personally use why you want them
to solve it I think that's the right
sweet spot I think that it's you know if
you get to a point where you just cannot
solve it it's like this is not fun
anymore so do you remember how long
torture path was roughly it was about to
36 38 hours oh my god we need to be
patient it just take it takes months for
us to create these things to craft these
things when these really ambassadors
just shoot we also don't sleep through
the whole period we do need to sleep a
little bit at some point yeah yeah you
guys probably haven't slept since no no
it's just no it's because it's around
the world and so like just as the
Americans are about ready to go a bed
that our buddies over a namely and start
playing or like okay the first yeah no I
mean Cameron and I were texting at 2:00
a.m.
2:30 a.m. watching people play and you
know are they gonna figure it out no and
the night I went to bed and I woke up in
like seven o'clock in the morning like
you haven't figured it out yet okay all
right yeah tag teams leave first watch
yeah Erin 22 was asking are there zombie
master prestige rewards we will talk
about that soon they say you gotta have
that Stalin Jay oh right yes oh wow he's
saving the day I'm the mother
with this locker cross explosion
chronologically what is the first
zombies for us yeah I mean we're okay so
if you want to get into the lore the
juicy Laurel absolutely the thule ins
when they first came across what we're
calling a lead on this mono magnetic or
and they figured out how to use it to
run with the Germans later called guys
crafts through the nervous systems of
their you know dead royalty and guards
they they that's how they first began to
gain their part that's how their empire
was established that's how they they
they kept their entire civilization
thriving and warm in the slowly frosting
over Antarctica and you know as you
there's there's lots of evidence in this
map of what other civilizations they
influenced and how they maintained to
that and really only through the you
know the grace of their own selfishness
and hunger for power it was a actually a
civil war combined with an a new kind of
ice age that that locked them down there
and will there will be some more letters
and notes that are detailing musasa as
drost n' digs into the history was
carefully
so we're gonna wave 24 even joining us
we've been streaming for almost an hour
on YouTube and GameSpot this is called
duties frozen dawn zombie map in World
War 2 from the shadow war expansion
which is out now you can play it if you
want to play alongside us or if you
we've been trying to figure out this
shield Easter Egg but we still have not
we have the creator of it right here
buddies he's not punching the proud
creator here seems like a specific
question kingdom hops was asking Cameron
can you have camera about Treader
zombies and is the drop rate for parts
for the smuggler low okay so the
treasures on these zombies that was um
I'll give you a little bit of lore
behind how about that because we don't
do a lot of hand waving we realized as
the as the Nazis knew they were going to
be moving across the face of Russia you
know the the original plan was to
involve the undead and Operation
Barbarossa what better way to go across
the frozen you know tundra of a lot of
the Russian front than with a group of
soldiers who don't need to eat or sleep
and I'm not afraid of cold however
behind them you were going to have the
sort of the Shepherd soldiers buying
them the actual Nazi forces and so the
certain undead were actually armed with
basically storage that they could give
for the soldiers that came behind the
living soldiers that came behind all of
the abilities The Electrician L devices
the the blitz machines that that our
heroes are using were originally created
by by you know the by Rideau or survivor
doe by by Stroud for for the Nazi
soldiers that later so that they could
both manage the undead and herd them and
and and be powered up as they went along
so that's not the treasure zombies
narrative we are serving as far as
numbers go I mean Jason do you want to
get into their the percentage drop there
because that's enough
we you know we tweak things all the time
you know we listen to you guys quite a
bit and we want to make things
especially kind of older things like
that a little bit more fun you know but
we have a numbers for you I'm sorry now
that'd be a little too much under the
hood we yeah I enjoy the inside baseball
stuff but yeah we I got another one from
Lucifer same ask Cameron Jason if they
can give us a nudge to if it's true that
the Raven Lords
betrayed Barbarossa and then through all
betrayed the Raven Lords be as vague as
needed I'm sorry haven't you been paying
attention
ahaha well they tune in 100 percent the
Barbarossa when he took this sword I
mean he had this meteoric rise to power
and this is actually an actual history
here was he was a minor Duke in Germany
he goes on this first crusade on the
king of Germany the king of Germany dies
he comes back and in a course of two
three years becomes the king of Germany
then becomes the Holy Roman Emperor and
is and so so we're saying he came across
this sword that he was on a ship that
was lost at sea he encountered you know
an opening in the went in to stay warm
to survival found the sword it was this
sword that that power his his rised
about his uh he had four dear friends
that were his warlords that he had you
know had helped him to succeed as far
that and they watched as this sword
gradually drove him insane as the power
and the voices there were there there's
something more that comes with this
sword it's not just something you can
plug in and have an undead army there
there's there's more to it and they
realized if they didn't act the key was
going to destroy the earth and and so
the the Raven Lords actually
assassinated him they assassinated him
they took apart his sword and they hit
it up so it's really it's their
mysteries that were first uncovering to
to get to the bottom of this the they
were I mean not only were they powerful
warlords but Barbarossa says he rose to
power had had christened them had
blessed them had had knighted them and
and gifted them with weapons that were
charged with his own with his own sword
as well so there's there's a lot of now
that's the Barbarossa portion of this
we're now going even more ancient we're
going further back in time and we're
recognizing if you look at some of the
hieroglyphics on the wall some stories
have been told and have to be told again
and again okay
you would mention a few people are
asking you had mentioned like other
sci-fi inspirations by other people were
asking is there are there any like older
stories that are biblical they are
asking about like a parallel between the
Four Horsemen of the Apocalypse and the
Raven Lords Atlantis and Thule right
older otto a fool I think I think you
there's a reason stories become
archetypes yeah whose reasons stories
become are told by by disparate cultures
on other sides of the planet for some
reason they tell these same stories
originally collectively yeah there are
stories of in South America there's
stories of a flood covering the earth
it's you know either there are these and
yeah and the the story of four powerful
beings who provide both death and
judgment and balance is something that
has been echoed time and time again and
so we're playing into that and of course
the you know this is a game mode that
did you know historically has had four
characters playing cooperatively with
each other and that just I don't know
dovetails nicely in with the appetite
it's nice to take that co-op and make it
harder like like diegetic stories and
and that was the fun as well behind the
idea of this this ancient foolin race is
is one of our fun ways of saying well
maybe these stories aren't aren't
archetypes because of the shared
humanity but maybe there is some shared
history maybe there were some some dark
overlords some you know some some
masterful advanced and horribly twisted
evil characters and in our past that you
know and it's often our fearful memories
are our most powerful ones and maybe
those are what
the legends by some of these cultures
yeah you think you think of like
cultural folklore and so often it's
about like monsters or like I don't know
like what's the Mexican one I'm thinking
of right now the fable a little come to
me every everybody Raider's thunk reason
yeah every culture has has a story of
magical beings there there are stories
of giants in just about every culture
story of dragons in every culture their
story of powerful beings who you know
we're kind of above the the even the
greatest kings of the mortal realm you
know and we even have pictures in the
people who were alive that had miss you
know fantastical stories about them like
Rasputin and Vlad I mean these guys are
horrible beings but also they started
off with a bit of a huge following
because they had something about them
that people wanted they tapped into
something so yeah so that magic figured
out around to tell us tell this kind of
a story so um so what so Aaron wave 26
Ricky how's it going how are you doing
this site is awesome like innocence yeah
really bring me through that in jiaying
who has saved me like five times
okay keys go to the one access we love
the idea of like the the site the death
raven again talking about one of these
archetypes this idea of death carrying a
scythe and why does that myth exists and
is there a reason is the metaphor of
course like reaping the grain and the
end of the season of growth being part
of something cyclical rather than just a
you know a stop sign we got we also have
questions about the colored grenades are
those linked to the main Easter Egg is
that something you can nudge people with
or is that something you want to leave
up to the to the zombie gods we like
even though the snows yeah yeah okay
cool good eye good eye okay
I don't know whose side I'm on I don't
know if I'm on yours so trying to keep
your secrets or a crown her mouth no we
kind of have to be best I mean there's
been some
using the contagion with that already I
wouldn't want to I wouldn't want an edgy
you guys are sharing great
so you said tortured passes the longest
it took everybody figure out the main
Easter Egg that's thirty eight hours and
what do you want now for this like
anymore Tenzin uh yeah I don't know I'm
predicting this because this is like the
team's thus far have moved through
elementary school they're just getting
to junior high yeah you know and you've
got to get a you got to get a PhD by the
end of this and so we've got things
things are gonna get things are gonna
get heavy
that's uh that's gotta be passing it's
always like do you guys um so like I
know with like destinies for instance
when the first team beats the raids huge
dealers new story a few guys get to like
call them out and like celebrate with
the first cows I mean we try to we
recognize when it happens we made sure
that we've got tools and abilities to
see who gets through first and we will
usually call them out on our honor on
our broadcast we'll send them we've got
a collection of letters we that we found
from the bureau so we we make sure we
send their way and decided to buy these
you know by thanks or no himself so keep
trying yeah keep grinding awesome well
we cannot close down a few minutes
unless there's something you want to
talk about or show actually we're about
to see maybe folks are walking through
this area one of my favorite things
about the Thule and architecture in this
level is it's mostly stone right it's
mostly stone and this like papyrus skin
that you find in one of the other areas
but in this area specifically you see
chains which is you know this is
supposed to be ten thousand years ago
you know how did they before G
metallurgy was a very primitive art and
you know if this civilization was lost
in time of course we didn't figure that
out
for a very long time but anything
important that we found in duel has been
metal you know the psifas metal dance
and metal those chains are metal so you
know I just yeah that's my dad joke I
told my kids to do again dad joke here
sorry yeah something else I wanted to
say I've seen some comments about this
this is something that was originally in
some of the dialogue that they didn't
get through via tool itself has been
trapped under the ice for the untold
millennium the end yet we've got gun
boxes we've got the Blitz machines and
everything else so I've seen a couple of
people questioning why are these things
down here you need to remember the when
you first start there's the wreckage of
some of these Nazi Zeppelin's around
here the Zeppelin's that carried the
undead that carried all these machines
and if you remember in the shadow thrown
the the process the attack process here
is the zombies of the very first tool
and the the undead moved these machines
into place because they know that the
forces that will be following behind
them both the Shepherd's and the Nazi
soldiers are going to be using those so
it was the Nazis shifting or the zombies
shifting into their their attack mode as
they always do on top of that on top of
that if you've heard the voices down
below the ice here there so there are
other forces that that want our heroes
to succeed so that one our heroes and
that goes yeah something start help you
so giving you that's why there's a
there's some of these moments again I
know this is not a necessary thing but
we always try to have an explanation for
everything you're gonna see it's never
gonna be it's because it's a game yeah
well that's cool you mentioned so
earlier in the stream you mentioned
Jason you were saying pay attention to
the whispers you're hearing yeah so
that's a tip for people watching the
show whispers and what you find in the
trials they're important for some the
blood quotes are vital all of them read
your notes read you've been picking up
all sorts of pages down there they're
important one of those reasons one of
the zombie teams that's been streaming
has mentioned the solution but they
didn't actually do it for the shield is
that what you said
someone who types oh yes they've
talked about the pieces gotcha what are
the members of the team mentioned it and
was soundly ignored by everybody and
also like everybody gonna have to pan
through there throughout here are times
yeah
or figure it out yourselves I mean leave
it the dust you guys how long you
survive 18 minutes si
either way this job thanks for playing
Jay yeah Ritchie thanks for here a team
yeah I did what I could
well everybody whether you join on
YouTube or GameSpot stream thank you so
much for joining us in the afternoon or
at night or morning wherever you're
watching from I know the UK crew has
been pretty busy since I don't think
this came out yeah yeah and then camera
Jason thanks so much for joining us any
last-minute things you want to say final
the shadow work with frozen dawn final
zombies map 5 final expansion from
sledgehammer before we get black ops 4
in October that's right get in play we'd
love your thoughts we'd love to hear
what you think what you loved about it
what you didn't this is all this is all
tasty data that we're gonna use to put
into everything we do moving forward so
we've been it's been an honor and a
privilege to be part of the zombies
community throughout this season it has
been something that we already are just
talking about so fondly and so I want to
echo the same thing thank you guys it's
been a pleasure and also good luck on
the next step
yes you'll get there yeah got 38 hours
the record to be that's right yeah yeah
that's the longest with a torture path
you mentioned all right well again thank
you guys so much for coming in and
congratulations on a year well-earned if
that's the right way to phrase it
world war ii shadow war is out now you
can go play that and try to catch up
with all these teams streaming zombies
good luck with that down a fool yeah
everybody thank you so much for joining
and stick around because we will be
streaming throughout the week as we
always do we'll see you then